they say they're on the streets to fight
government attempts to centralize power
and crack down on dissent
thousands of people turned out on monday
across bolivia
[Music]
protesters are concerned about a law the
government wants to pass to fight
illicit profits and terrorism
says the law will hurt people like her
we want the law to be annulled there are
articles that harm us that could make us
lose all our belongings they should
fight for our country for our well-being
we are here for our children
experts say the law violates rights to
due process and could be used to
persecute political opponents
the nation is deeply divided since evo
morales was forced out of office in 2019
after a disputed election that forced
him to leave the country
from morales mass party won the
elections last year with a landslide
vote during his state of the union
speech on monday he said he has the
responsibility of helping bolivia move
forward and that's why he's hoping to
pass a series of laws that will help the
country recover from the pandemic
when the people voted last year it was
set clear that they did not want
unconstitutional governments and gave us
legitimacy to govern
it told us they want political economic
and social stability to advance they
trusted the economic reconstruction of
our country of the health system after
the pandemic the right to education and
showed us the way of peace through
justice
but not everyone agrees in the lowlands
city of santa cruz the stronghold for
the conservative opposition protesters
blocked roads and set tires on fire
the government says the opposition is
using the law as an excuse to generate
instability in the country
the strike while widespread does not
have the support of a major labor union
close to the government
but on monday thousands showed their
concern on the streets
they believe the laws to fight what the
government calls illicit profits could
lead to an attack on private property
and that's why they vow to remain on the
streets until the government gives in to
their demands
[Music]
al jazeera